روايات عده والواقعه واحده 100 طالبات
الايرانيات في المشافي والسبب هجمات
بالمواد الكيماويه هرم السلطه الايرانيه
من جانبه يستنكر ويشجب المرشد الايراني
علي خامني دور للنظام في حوادث تسمم ووصف
تصميم الايرانيات بانه جريمه لا تغتفر على
السلطات تتبع قضيه تصميم التلميذات بجديه
هذه جريمه لا تغتفر تجب معاقبه مرتكبي هذه
الجريمه بقسوه الرجل الثاني في ايران
الرئيس الايراني ينكر ويرفض الاعتراف
بوقوع حالات تسمم للطالبات ويصفها بمؤامره
من العدو تسميم الطالبات حلقه اخرى من
العدو لاثاره التوتر والتهويل داخل
المجتمع ونشر الخوف
اما السلطه القضائيه في ايران فقد اكتفت
بالتعهد بتطبيق عقوبه الاعدام على
المتسببين في تسميم الطالبات كانت الحكومه
اعلنت فتح تحقيق في اسباب التسمم الا انها
لم تعلن حتى الان توقيف اي شخص
التصريحات الايرانيه المتضاقطه بشان
التسمم رافقها تشكيك من قبل السلطات في
اسبابها وصل حد وصف حالات التسمم بالتمثيل
او انها جاءت من جماعات متشدده ترفض تعليم
الفتيات
الخبراء يقولون ان هناك فرضيتين حول تسمم
الطالبات اما ان يكون السبب شغب المراهقات
او الخوف الجماعي رغم مرور اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر على الهجمات الكيماويه لم يتم حتى
الان تحديد المتهم بهذه الظاهره
لكنها طالت حتى اللحظه مئه الطالبات
وعشرات المدارس وسببت حالا من الذعر بين
الاهالي والطالبات